This is a country in motion.
The land of hard work and independence.
Its people bound only by their imagination.
In Detroit, companies like Shinola are reconnecting with the past,...
...building a better future.
Because of entrepreneurship, Detroit is coming back one step at a time.
By working with their hands, people are dreaming again.
These are our people, our product, our power.
This is our time.
Shinola represents America at some level, I believe.
It represents the notion that anything is possible.
It shows that what this country was built on is real and is still here.
The people of this city are what Shinola is so excited about...
...and what really brought us here is the people's tenacity...
...and they're willing to be part of such an interesting comeback.
Bicycles and watches are an extension of oneself.
I hope the legacy of Shinola would be that...
...we're able to sustain and grow this great idea of making things in America...
...and we can get more people on that bandwagon...
...to support what we're doing.
And that this is just the beginning of a stronger revival of Detroit...
...and US manufacturing, not just in Detroit.
It's that thing that's coming back:...
...the reinvigoration of manufacturing in America...
...and showing the world that it might have left our shores,...
...but it's still here and we're still here and we're doing it again.